[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's been a few weeks since we last had
a meet-up but it's worth the wait
today's update is monumental if you're
new around here this is the series in
which we look at all the map
updates for potential clues to the live
event and the subtle subplots that are
hidden away
it's now week three of season four and
if you'd be so kind
you can use code adamaru for all your
purchasing needs
uh self-promotion anyway let's do this
[Music]
where shall we start today maybe the
stark industries update
nah that can wait because we have
something so strange it has to be seen
right away so last time we met up i told
you about the ghost and shadow npcs
who were chilling out in retail row and
the authority well this week
they have gone completely i am shooketh
my discord and i spent the week
attempting to get those two together to
see what happens
but we failed every time but the npc
gods took pity on us because right now
in game get your backside over to this
gas station
and slowly venture inside the two npcs
are now in the same location
but they aren't fighting oh no these
guys are having the most epic of dance
offs
i sat here and watched for 10 minutes as
they slowly became the bestest buddies
in the whole wide world
they now officially put bros before
evil dictatorship organizations what did
you think i was gonna say
[Music]
okay on to the stark update and look at
the size of this thing
the stark solar panels actually have an
official name now
they are temporal beacons allowing stark
to pull things from different worlds
to this battle royal island he brought
his mega corporation
with some cool details such as this desk
setup
and of course the avengers round table
making sure nobody is at the head of the
table
and everyone is equal just seeing his
suits
is just mind blowing across the way is
the start garage
garage garage you do you i first thought
this was for his motor cars but then i
read the email that came with the update
and it reveals that stark is going to
modify the battle bus
that sounds epic doesn't it could he be
creating a weaponized battle bus to
fight galactus
i hope so over the years we've had many
battle bus variations
and right now there isn't one on the map
so let's keep an eye on this
there is so much more to uncover here in
this sokovia-sized slab of land
have you noticed the cabins dotted
around well one of those
is hugely important i watched avengers
end game last night and
recognized this cabin right away this is
tony stark's home
in end game and i love it three thousand
too soon too soon my bad everything is
set up as close as identical as possible
and just like in the movie there is a
hidden base underneath
for tony to work on wormhole quantum
physics like all dads do in their spare
time
and to double down on this there is a
direct comparison to the movie
as his suit is right here right in the
feels
snaps all around there's also a memorial
here
i won't tell you why there's a memorial
here watch end game maybe
i suddenly remembered our lord and
savior graham the gnome was directly in
the line of fire from those temporal
beacons
i am happy to report he is all well and
good and judging us all silently like
he's always done but around the island
genomes are disappearing suddenly
posters for a mysterious new elixir from
the slurp company
can be spotted advertising this gnome
too this is the part where i ask you
guys to name this guy
what shall we call him he's quite dapper
he's quite elegant
please give him a great name i'll be in
the comments like usual looking for
suggestions
the real genome mastermind is actually
on the island already
go to the very south the very bottom and
surrounded by those missing gnomes
here's the slurp dude here's what
happens
when you get close enough
well i wasn't expecting that maybe he uh
doesn't need a name
actually knowing fortnite developers
this gnome will likely be back
as a gnome hulk let's keep vigilant
and uh check back next update
[Music]
over to the greatest poi ever seen
hut watch baby once again hot watch has
evolved
more shallots more shallots more chairs
and pallets have appeared and are
beginning to be set
up but take a look at the walls they are
being renovated
only slightly but check out this archway
door pretty cool
and are the walls plastered now hut
watching chapter two
is taking so long but i'm up for that in
fact they're taking so long everywhere
the cleanup on the street above
is still going on 11 weeks to move one
vehicle
do you think hot watch is almost
complete or should we expect more
i personally believe it will be
destroyed just to spite us
while we are here on the map get your
butt down to camp cod
because things are about to change here
the old
archive of chapter one items has gone
vanished
building an all so it's looking like
something is coming to this spot later
this week
i'm wondering if it's a coincidence that
another temporal rift
brought the marvel villain the collector
to the game in the snowy mountains above
camp cod the final micro update last
week saw the inclusion of the creator
aka tanelia taivan
in the comic books he is an ancient of
the universe he's kind of like noah and
his ark
collecting specimens before each
civilization is gone forever
gone forever eh i'm glad he took a clone
of graham and there's also a meteor
shard from chapter one
and the clock face from tilt it but this
egg
is way too big to be that one from polar
peak right what am i missing here what
is this egg from
could the collector be responsible for
the missing items the cam caught
in fact let's go back a whole week to
the smaller updates on the map
four micro temporal shifts occurred
dragging the worlds of the x-men ant-man
black panther and the collector
like we just talked about each of these
have a crazy amount of detail and clues
about the future
for example the prison container is a
reference to
trask a dedicated hater of mutants and
inhumans
who created the sentinels which are now
currently wrecked on a hillside
this update told us that trask is
continuing to test on mutants
i first thought this was a hint to the
movie timeline in which magneto frees
mystique and the juggernaut
aren't the juveniles but on closer
inspection
this looks to be a nod to the ultimate
marvel series in which a potential cure
for cancer is stolen from peter parker's
dad
and trask begins aggressive testing upon
it and that so happens to be
venom the ant-man appearance is another
area which blows my mind feeling as
small as an ant
but again there are things of note first
the dog ball for anton
that's the oversized ant pet of ant-man
and then there are these vials these are
pin particles which give ant-man the
ability to change his size
and to confirm all this the pym tech
signage is close by
there's actually a glitch where we can
resize our characters to be tiny i'm
sure you've seen it in the past
but what if this is not a hint to that
but instead to what ant-man can do the
other way
his oversizing ability instead giant man
hey we're gonna need a lot of
superheroes to take the fight to
galactus
he eats islands like this for breakfast
we're gonna need more superheroes
the third update is bittersweet the
black panther
i know the world stopped to pay their
respects last week but i never got that
chance so i think it's time now
chadwick you shall be missed sir when i
make these videos i usually ask for a
hot watch forever shout in the comments
but that hashtag would not exist without
the black panther movie
back in 2018 so let's change that and
pay our respects
can i get a wakanda forever below thank
you kindly
oh before i get emotional let's move on
to another pli that landed today
heroes park this really confused me
because heroes park is a place in the dc
universe
near the daily planet building and the
statue here looks mighty similar to that
one too
i did a little marvel research and the
best i can find
is in the current marvel's avengers game
when the avengers disbanded or should i
say
disassembled heroes park saw the
memorial of captain america
my knowledge isn't good enough here so
i'm sure someone is watching and they
can geek out far better than i can
and help us understand this update
[Music]
a couple more things before we finish
firstly it's a sad time
as the island home of the coral buddies
aka
the wobbly blobs has vanished from
existence
i mean he's totally gone which is
strange right so is the heart-shaped
island needed for groups challenges
it's gone too so maybe this was all a
mistake
we'll find out soon i guess but finally
let's finish on something better than
this
down at ferris bueller's house the crane
which was helping a smaller crane which
was helping a car
which had fallen over the edge has uh
now fallen too
and it can't get up we are one step
closer to the crane graveyard i've
always wanted
we've followed this story for over a
year now and every so often every month
or two
it gets better and better gg epic
developers
stay awesome
so there we have it week three is in the
history books as galactus continues to
approach for a final battle in a month
or two
on screen now are the legends who have
used code adamaru and sent me a twitter
dm with roof
i'm adam grenade over there and my dms
are open i believe i have now replied to
everyone who bought a battle pass
rocking my code but just in case i've
missed anyone
thank you very much much appreciated
right i'm sure you're sick of my voice
by now so i'll get back to my dance off
with shadow and ghost
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you